DAVID HARBOUR
Hey everybody, in Black Widow,
I play Red Guardian.
A superhero spy who is also a dad.
So you ready
for some zingers?
SCARLETT JOHANSSON
Hmm, if we must, yeah.
DAVID HARBOUR
Hey, hey guys...
Why did the
Black Widow wear a disguise?
DAVID HARBOUR
Because she was a SPY-der.
FLORENCE PUGH
[Laughing] Oh my god...
DAVID HARBOUR
I don't even have to read 'em from
the book, I know 'em.
What are a spy's
favorite type of shoes?
Sneakers.
[Laughing]
DAVID HARBOUR
Hey, guys?
SCARLETT JOHANSSON
You like that one?
DAVID HARBOUR
Guys, what do you call a Canadian spy?
A double EH-gent.
I myself don't
even like that one
Last week I discovered an Australian
gorilla spying on me, and,
y'know what I told him?
Y'know what I said?
I said "hey, don't PRY... Mate."
Don't, "pry, mate" but
it's also like the word "primate."
Hey, guys? Clint Barton's brother has
a super smelling ability? They call him...
Hawknose.
'Cause his real
name is Hawkeye.
Just admit it, you love my jokes.
FLORENCE PUGH
I actually liked a few.
DAVID HARBOUR
Yeah, see? I'll take it.